[Music]
5 15 on your friday morning
congratulations to the nevada pta's
teacher and administrators of the year
both are from robert and sandy ellis
elementary in the inspirota neighborhood
of henderson
the principal dr sean cochran hall
recognized not only for emphasizing
student achievement but also for
community involvement and open
communications with the staff the
students and their parents
teacher of the year first grade teacher
sarah ward praised by nominating parents
for her enthusiastic support of literacy
the school had a hundred percent
participation in their readathon and
ward applied for and got a grant to
install one of those really cool little
free libraries on the campus
and those awards presented by the nevada
pta's president-elect kaylee fox as well
as the current president rebecca garcia
now if you know something that's cool at
school we would love to hear from you
let us know cool is cool under the
community tab at 8newsnow.com or just
email cool at school at 8newsnow.com a
lot going on down there at robert and
sandy ellis elementary that partnerships
with the hoa down at inspirada and
partnerships with the nevada partnership
for homeless youth so they're giving
those elementary kids life experiences
at an early age i love that and it's you
know it's also worth pointing out school
starts pretty soon
there's less than i don't know what it
is but the moms and dads might be going
okay good